[Music]  welcome to my body  ladies gentlemen are you ready to see  the next big thing let's hear it for the  new change it's cool what's that honey  all children must be accompanied by an  adult you're coming with me young lady  [Music]  hello maybe we could try and be friends  you're gonna stay here tonight not you  mom oh I knew that you judging me bra  yeah you being here is like the best  thing that happened to me why don't you  put weapons in a robot something  terrible is about to happen  holy toast seven seven two three is our  only hope  [Music]  they're just wait which injustice in the  world together we can fix it I promise I  got your back  [Music]  No  he's so cool what do you call him my  friend Wow thank you for opening me oh  look out here I go closing  [Music]  [Music]